let's say you're going to you're going
to you're not going to find your answers
and philosophy not just going to throw
away philosophy how much you go lower
what might you looked what activities
would be might get you out of that
problem they might solve those problems
for you in a way by just you know
ignoring lose what ya you could you
could you could say yeah you could
become sort of a skeptic or a cynic and
say these are all just ideas and once
you start to accept bathroom perspective
you still have the problems how should I
put my life sooo what are you going to
do which direction anything to go you
could watch TV and your mural some
people do that that's a way to get
through it right after a while the the
rent has to be paid though to get bored
with just watching TV all the time I
suppose you can pursue a life of
pleasure
you can find ways to lose yourself you
don't actually have to be a Christian
philosopher to think about this hi dear
actually he thought that modernity
Nietzsche thought these are laws to
thought that modernity lost sight of it
you know these great ideals philosophy
had left nowhere and so what should you
do this is what he calls the problem of
neil ism what do you do with values have
become devalued another alternative
would be philosophy actually looks
elsewhere it humbles itself and looks
elsewhere for answers to these problems
and when it does it accepts things into
itself it still works on them as
philosophy doesn't reason doesn't go on
holiday as soon as it starts looking at
faith but it starts to become much more
receptive and it starts to say I don't
have the answers to everything this way
of life is not going to be the answers
to every they talk about it very like
the ecclesiastics like that yeah
the fundamental problem in Ecclesiastes
is this guy has actually thought through
a lot of stuff and he doesn't he can't
make sense and you know who is it in the
the persona of quota some types of
Solomon it's supposed to be somebody who
belongs to this wisdom tradition and
they have tried to make sense of the
fact what's what's the one thing that
really sticks and enthusiastic chasing a
fool in well that's part of the problem
that all turns out to be vanity it all
turns out to be chasing after what's the
one thing that really blocks what's up
he's not exactly yeah why is it that you
know not only am I going to die like a
dog like everybody else even though I'm
really bright and I've studied all these
things they all turned on to be vanity
why is it that there is good there is
bad and somehow good people get it you
know in the neck and evil people go
unpunished and he doesn't say there is
no God because it doesn't doesn't throw
religion of Sciences this really does
not make sense and you can tell that it
bothers how does the book actually does
it end with a repudiation of
okay where is it and by rentals I don't
know but I do know that there is still
good the author doesn't reject the faith
so yeah Christianity well this is this
before Christian Jewish revelation is
answering problems that arranged for
human beings remember his philosophy is
a thoroughly human way of life it's in
some respects almost the highest
expression of the possibilities for
Humanity the intellect life of the mind
but then you may find out Dallas a
philosophy that's really doing itself
right we'll find out that it isn't the
top that it has to look to something
else and now the way is open for
Christian philosophy this is where we
have the problem of the supernatural
what is what is the problem how can
human culture how can human reason
address itself to something which turns
out to have been addressing itself to
humanity long before humanity even
started to listen how can it take in
something that's greater than itself how
can it engage the info without losing
itself in the process how can human
beings in what's greatest about them in
what God made them to do too thick to
know to lob through knowledge to pursue
how can that turn to faith without
therefore now thereby losing itself
that's the problem of the supernatural
innocence and he says philosophy is
ignored and you know if you think about
where we are today and you think about
where blown down on his culture were at
that time we're really in the same
position what comes to philosophy when
it comes to culture and gentlemen
imagine philosophy as sort of the apex
of intellectual culture most
intellectual culture that was he being
generated in our society is closing the
door to to not just theology again
what's somebody who said what is
theologies theology is study of God
Thomas said talk about God ultimately
theology should refers beyond to
something which is supposed to be
ultimately great ultimate reality it's
supposed to open us up to what truly is
and society can be structured in such a
way that its highest intellectual
products actually close this off to that
lonedell thought that and again this
would be why Christian philosophy is
relevant really with philosophy ought to
be doing is opening up those doors
instead now how will pro this have to do
with you as not you're not philosophers
your theologians well again think about
when you're doing theology are you using
philosophy where are you going to get
your philosophy
how many of you are planning on going on
for more advanced studies okay so while
you're there you're going to have to
study some philosophy you have yes I'm
here too much is the party that they've
studied some philosophy classes as part
of their formation so if you're going to
use some some theology those theologians
they studied philosophy how do you know
whether their philosophy is really good
philosophy yeah you do philosophy to
figure out whether philosophy is good
for you take some people as your
guidance do you want to pick guide to
actually some of them may not actually
be Christians to you know we were
talking about this a little bit earlier
a lot of 20th century philosophy that
was done in Europe is actually very
wrapped in the sense of turn towards the
the left intellectually and its
liberation from this liberation from
that critique of this and reach into
that and some of that can be quite
valuable I wouldn't want to buy into
those those projects wholesale and you
can look at the roots of some of those
those philosophers you could think of
say Nietzsche for example marx and
nietzsche and marks you wouldn't want to
necessarily buy into their projects
wholesale you couldn't be a christian to
do so because mark says not only
religion is the opiate of the masses he
says that that religion is a form of
false consciousness so you know thinking
that Christianity is true and being a
fourth attacks Marxist they're just not
compatible but you could take a lot from
are in order to do philosophy well you
could take bits and pieces of those
critical aspects to try to open up gaps
lonedell was doing so now interestingly
blundell was very very see to make sure
that he was not doing theology because
if you were doing theology you could get
trouble if you're just doing philosophy
then you're just doing philosophy and
they may not like you you know talking
bad about Thomas Aquinas or something
like this isn't the time Thomas Aquinas
to serve you know
rule the roost but if you were doing
theology that you could actually be
century for that so he made sure to say
I'm always just doing philosophy what do
we call them today we actually call the
fundamental theologian fundamental
theology is that branch of theology that
looks for the conditions for the
acceptance of the work and what has to
be in there in order for the human being
the rational human being to open
themselves up and to accept the word and
to in communities and for this have some
sort of effect there's actually an
interesting book out there by Chronicle
here of the word which does precisely
that it's very indebted to Marie's blown
down and so ultimately these things
about Christian philosophy they have a
lot to do with the ology so now this
would be a good time much time have we
got left yeah we're about give me give
any questions complaints criticisms
could you I think Josh was asking maybe
for some resource Mont for some
resources I mean could you maybe just
point us off top of your head to a work
or two if we wanted to read more such
thing even introductory never to do with
your source of our having it as
Christian philosophy guess Christian
philosophy or either one I guess if you
could find us a way in from an
undergraduate point of view would you
recommend something and putting on this
pot or may not be dodgin animal well i
would actually one thing i would
actually recommend to most of you is
reading blown dells book actual
it's a really great piece of philosophy
the one problem with it is that he's
engaging a lot of philosophers and does
not quit know who he's actually engaging
said that's but for later resourceful
throw up the guy that I actually like
the best is already too blue back then
that which book of his to to pick out
we've read discovery of God okay yeah
undergraduate Senate's works very well
he also has a book forget the title but
it's about contemporary forms of atheism
right modern yeah music and that's a
good one because it's a lead into all
these sort of historical developments
and it gives you an idea of why why we
can't just regurgitate Thomas Aquinas
why we have to loop the loop our laptops
phones more than will help clear faith
you can see a good idea why we have to
think of these things somewhat
differently the modern period so yeah
let's say that you could start
there isn't any as far as I know there
isn't any like single volume mount book
about resource of all theologians and
philosophers geared towards undergrads
that could be something good to ride it
actually thank you I guess Fergus cars
20th century Roman Catholic theology
isn't there he does some of that yeah
but it's broader than just that yes
there's a lot of could be well let's
give a round of applause